des salles de concert une cité des
sciences et de l'industrie
une cité de la musique un parc de 55
hectares une grande halle d'exposition
en 40 ans la ville être ses
métamorphoses à l'espace parisien s'est
imposé comme un site culturel
incontournable
loin très loin de l'atmosphère des
années 60
marché aux bestiaux abattoirs dès le
19ème siècle c'est à ça que ressemble l
avis net dans les années 60 la ville de
paris envisage même de créer un marché
international de la viande il faut alors
reconstruire les abattoirs devenu
vétuste mais dix ans après le début des
travaux
l'opération s'avère finalement trop
coûteuse le chantier est stoppé et
l'ensemble des activités du site
supprimés alors tous ces bâtiments
auxquels on pense qu'ils sont les
bâtiments récemment construit c'est à
dire ceux qui ont goûté depuis béton ne
seront pas rasé comme certains ont pu le
penser mais reconverti la page est
tournée
dans la symbolique marque un nouveau
temps pour la vigne un nouveau temps
initiée par valéry giscard d'estaing le
président veut en finir avec cette
friche industrielle 170 il demande une
étude pour la réalisation d'un musée des
sciences et de l'industrie
le futur musée lui sera construit sur
des structures existantes celles de
l'ancienne salle des ventes du marché de
la viande
quatre hectares au sol un musée qui sera
trois fois plus grand que beaubourg et
qui correspond aux besoins nouveaux et
réelle de notre temps dès son élection
en 1981 françois mitterrand reprend le
projet de réhabilitation de la villette
auquel il ajoutera une cité de la
musique
son ministre de la culture jack lang
supervisait l'etrat nous allons ouvrir
un concours international pour nous
assurer de du concours des meilleurs
architectes nous allons cravacher nous
allons aller assez vite et nous
souhaiterions que
je répète avant cinq ans cet ensemble
soit 0 pt et dès 1984 les inaugurations
s'enchaînent le zénith le 12 janvier la
grande halle
un an plus tard la cité des sciences et
de l'industrie en 1986 et le parc de la
villette en 1987 la cité de la musique
cher à françois mitterrand ouvrira ses
portes en 1995
treize ans après le début des travaux ce
monument était pensé pour servir la
cause de la musique et de tous ceux qui
autour de la planète s'intéresse aux
cette note professionnels spectateurs
étudiants chercheurs des abattoirs au
site culturel le nouveau visage de la
villette attire plus de 10 millions de
visiteurs par an
transformation réussie
[Musique]